hey guys I'm Ryan right hey guys I'm
Veronica that trailer has dropped that I
[ __ ] have been waiting for for the
longest [ __ ] time Quentin Tarantino's
the hateful eight script got leaked and
Veronica and I had been watching a lot
of Tarantino films like yeah I showed
her Kill Bill Vol 1 & 2 this year when I
showed her Django and I just started
showing her jackiebrown like two days
ago so I'm excited to see this trailer
let's do this so excited
[Music]
nice got room for one moat
[Music]
they call him the hang
when the handbills their dead allowed
the rest of us just shoot you in the
back come up on top of perch somewhere
bringing a dead / saddle but when John
Ruth the hangman catches you you hey
[Music]
this here is Daisy Dahmer goop she's
wanted dead or alive for murder that Sun
comes out I'm taking this woman to hang
there anybody here committed to stopping
me from doing that well well well looks
like Minnie's haberdashery is about to
get cozy for the next
one of them sells
is not what he says he is move a little
strange you gonna get a boat hour
warning not a question a book
now we're talking
70-millimeter what does that mean it's
gonna show in 70-millimeter it's like hi
film quality oh wow that looks really
cool man it looks real it doesn't look
like it's gonna be like his best one yet
but there's still a lot of aspects to it
I like I know we haven't I haven't shown
you Reservoir Dogs yet but waiting on
that wait for the right time you got to
really be in the mood to watch Reservoir
Dogs it kind of reminds me of that
because in that movie it primarily takes
place in one location with a bunch of it
with an ensemble takes place in this
warehouse this film looks like it's
taking place in this house for like a
large portion of the film I mean it
looks like they go out and stuff but it
doesn't look like as adventurous as
let's say like Django Unchained was it
seems like you this hateful eight it's
gonna be about the character
interactions between them I don't know
it just kind of look like an adventure
film though doesn't it yeah I mean
there's I'm just saying him probably
might not be as adventurous as some of
his later films like Kill Bill glorious
I didn't quite grasp exactly what
they're doing
do they not give that up in the trailer
did I miss that um I it's so slightly
confusing but Tarantino movies are never
really that simple to understand except
for uh [ __ ] Kill Bill so what they
don't reveal is what the betrayal and
deception is yeah that's what I mean it
seems like it's gonna be a lot of
character twists and reveals you know
something a little bit different than
what I'm kind of used to seeing
Tarantino do like I'm sure it's gonna
deliver on the violence and stuff and
it's gonna have the badass dialog but
I'm interested to see a film that's
about suspicion you know that I've never
seen Tarantino really do that you always
get a good grasp of who the characters
are whether they're good or bad and this
one it looks like there's gonna be like
a little bit of a guessing game going on
did you say what was his name Tim Roth
Tim raffia he usually plays good
villains right like he's good yeah he's
good at playing the villain well he's
one of the stars of Reservoir Dogs he's
he's that thief in the opening of Pulp
Fiction I love the way he sticks with
his cast ya know I mean he's got Sam
Jackson back and he has said that Sam
Jackson says his dialogue better than
anyone else I want to see how he is in
this movie because I think he's
fantastic I agree with that like he's
really real
good with dialogue I can't imagine
memorizing all the time samuel l.jackson
had in a lot of movies he kind of has
like this over the top and her energy
but he's so committed to it that you buy
it yeah then Tarantino films he knows
how to really create a character in
these films you know like he was in Pulp
Fiction he was great and then in Jackie
Brown I loved him even more and then
he's in Django Unchained a totally
different character and I feel like
we're gonna get that again to Tim Roth
though you know I like his accent and
everything but he kind of seems like
he's playing the role that like
Christoph Waltz would have played well
you don't really see much of that
character is he is he like a comedic it
seems like really in this there seems
like there's a comic aspect to it I
think that's something that a lot of
people don't are not so aware of is that
Tarantino films tend to have a sense of
humor
oh yeah and a lot of people don't
associate them with humor but there's
always a lot of humor in his films you
know and I feel like we're really gonna
get that and Kurt Russell was one of my
favorite actors growing up and he worked
with him in death Proof hey wouldn't you
know rocking the shirt you know I met
Tarantino once and I happen to be
wearing the shirt and he said he liked
your shirt he said he liked your shirts
not what he said he said I liked your
tailor he's witty he's good with his
lines
yeah and Kurt Russell looks cool man I
mean he's badass death Proof wasn't the
biggest success at the box office but
it's cool to see Kurt Russell returning
with Tarantino because he's [ __ ]
awesome to this day he's one of the
coolest actors and that Channing Tatum
was rumored to be in this I didn't see
him in the trailer but that would be
pretty [ __ ] sweet Channing - yeah I
wonder what kind of role he would be
playing oh and Michael Madsen is
returning
so yeah this cast is assembled well it's
cool to see Tarantino returning to a
form of primarily character interaction
that's what at least looks like and he's
got a lot of his his cast is here you
know he got Sam Jackson he got Tim Roth
he got Michael Madsen bass bringing back
Zoe Bell who was introduced in death
Proof she was the one hanging off the
front of the car this stunt woman I know
the script got leaked but the script got
leaked for inglorious basterds I mean I
even read the leaked script before the
movie came out I mean glorious bastards
yeah
should happen I don't know but I'm so
glad that he's still doing this film
because I know he was going to turn it
into a novel but it started off as a
script it's meant to be a film
Tarantino's best full medium his film so
this is going to be really cool to watch
did that note say that it was his eighth
film yeah and it's called hateful eight
yeah
coincidence I think not anyway guys
thanks for tuning in and mentioning that
was out seriously thank you if you're
new to the channel you can subscribe to
the reel rejects you can check out
Veronica's channel where there's a lot
of acoustic covers originals and the
logs you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram Twitter I have a vine and
periscope chilling has a Facebook
Instagram and Twitter
man I'm gonna surpass him soon in
Twitter and Instagram so just you know
keep telling yourself that baby keep
talking something I'm gonna surpass you
you tell yourself Kenneth Carrasco
Congrats on getting 200k subscribers
this channel is pure entertainment
laughter and time-to-time emotional and
dick jokes everything you need oh my god
he was saying there were emotional dick
jokes Oh sometimes it's emotional and
there's dick jokes there's other jokes
besides dick jokes yeah sort of every
video watch I always end up with a smile
thank you Ryan and the rest of the
rejects for the work you do by the way
I'm actually working a small movie
project soon involving Batman Nightwing
in Red Hood sweet hopefully you can
check it out when it's released
finally can I get a shout-out Kenneth
Carrasco dude I'm glad we can
consistently entertain you my friend
rascal um your profile pic you look like
a badass dude you look Filipino man I am
Filipino do you got sensitive eyes those
eyes can make a well you look like you
can get a transgender nothing wrong with
that transgenders are good people but I
feel like you're going to end up with a
transgender it's not an insult it's a
compliment all right because who doesn't
want a woman with boobies but also a
penis just stop just stop stop stop
that's enough because you're gonna
offend somebody out there if you had a
penis
well I'd be scared because you didn't
start off with a penis so you would have
to have grown a penis hence we would
have to go to the doctors go through our
insurance maybe pay out-of-pocket who
knows is that what your other people do
they grow their penis yeah female
Kenneth Carrasco knows he grew his penis
right so the transgender is right they
only move on they grow their genitals